throughout the 1920s Dell publications
served as the industry standard on print
media led by a syndicated series of
newspaper strips called famous funnies
these publications were the go-to source
for comedy satire and adventure but a
new age was emerging one which would
force Adele publications out of the
limelight as a competitor emerged with a
flagship character that would change
print media forever
with Superman established as the
preeminent superhero following his
introduction in Action Comics issue
number one in 1938 and his first
appearances Superman's powers were
largely simple because pulp comics
predated Superman's arrival by serving
as a popular source of pictural stories
in the 1920s and the 1930s ranging from
detective works to heroics while
characters like Doc Savage the shadow
and the phantom detective like any kind
of superpowers in the traditional sense
their popularity was largely rooted in
the fact that they fought crime using
their personal attributes including a
photographic memory martial arts as well
as their intelligence where the goal of
Siegel and Shuster was to move heroes
into a new echelon by introducing powers
a balance had to be maintained by
changing things enough that Superman
would invoke interest but not so much
that he seemed too far-fetched in the
eyes of prospective fans to this end
with his original introduction Siegel
and Shuster established that Superman's
powers were a byproduct of his alien
physiology and as a result the Man of
Steel could leap 1/8 of a mile or the
length of two football fields lifts
tremendous weights run faster than an
express train and withstand artillery at
point-blank range however with the
introduction of Superman came creations
from other publication companies like
Fawcett comics who were looking to
capitalize on and replace Superman with
their own heroes like Captain Marvel in
response DC found itself swept up in a
maelstrom of frenzied attempts to keep
Superman on par with his competitors
some of whom had already demonstrated
the power of flight and so in Action
Comics issue number 8
Superman was demonstrated as being able
to outrace a speeding bullet for the
very first time an action comics issue
number 11 he was provided with x-ray
vision allowing him to see through walls
as well as super hearing which provided
him with the ability to spy on and
eliminate criminal activities and an
action comics issue number 20 he was
demonstrated as having super breath
which allowed him to knock over
individuals who intended harm to
themselves or others while these powers
were largely introduced within the
context of the story and made Superman
virtually indestructible and incredibly
powerful in comparison to the technology
of the time these abilities also left
the Man of Steel open to the possibility
of expanding his powers something that
saw fruition under Fleischer Studios in
1941 with her introduction of eight
short length Superman features
[Music]
as a now-defunct animation company based
out of New York in formed by Max and
David Fleischer it was during the
creation of these films that Superman
would first gained the power of flight
have you been contacted by its parent
company Paramount Pictures for the
purpose of creating a series of animated
shorts based on the newly created
Superman but in the midst of a project
titled mr. bud goes to town the goal of
the Fleischer brothers was to keep their
workload simple and to focus on only one
film at a time in order to ensure
quality over quantity
however because paramount was the parent
company and served to finance the flight
respects the idea was to effectively
turn down the requests without damaging
the contract between the two to this end
the Fleischer's quoted paramount an
outrageous price of $100,000 per episode
which was four times higher than the
$25,000 cost of producing other
animations of the time like Popeye the
Sailor furthermore once paramount had to
go Shi a to the price down to $50,000
the Fleischer's found the depiction of
Superman leaping 1/8 of a mile seemed
silly given the high quality of the
animated features and the fact that by
Wiz colleagues issued number 5
Captain Marvel had already demonstrated
the ability to fly and so after
contacted DC Comics the flashes were
granted approval to remove the ability
to leap distances and replace it with a
power flight with fans relishing it both
the idea the Superman could fly as well
as the increased sense of urgency that
could be created from his races to save
Lois Lane with only moments to spare
this concept was rolled over into the
comic books and by Action Comics issue
number 123 in 1948 flight was officially
added to Superman's repertoire as an
enhancement to his ability to leave
incredible distances however with the
ever increasing expanse of his powers
and offhanded ways based on particular
stories the problems faced by fans was
that some powers remained while others
were removed this was compounded on
following the end of World War 2 when
the idea of the late 1940s to the late
1950s saw Superman thrown into the realm
of science fiction because alien
invaders and creatures from space for
increasing in popularity with the
introduction of shows like 1951 steals
of tomorrow a spiritual predecessor to
The Twilight Zone the stories of
Superman were adjusted to include the
use of science fiction concepts
furthermore in addition to the need for
DC to create new material in order to
keep up with competitors like Captain
Marvel from Fawcett comics whose powers
were continually being expanded on to
keep up with an overshadow Superman
DC was also facing a crisis following
the departure of Jerry Siegel and Joe
Shuster in 1947 as a byproduct of a
lengthy legal battle over the rights of
Superman without Siegel and Shuster to
continue the trend of overseeing the
expansion of Superman's character and
stories the duties of editor were turned
over to Mort Weisinger while Weisinger
had worked with DC Comics in the early
1940s and was instrumental in creating
characters like Aquaman and Green Arrow
with the departure of Siegel and Shuster
his attention was now turned to
remodeling their creation by elevating
the powers of Superman and in doing so
establish a self-contained world along
with a super family to this end where
the era of 1948 to 1958 is largely
referred to as the Lost Decade and that
many of the stories were considered
silly and largely ignored with Mart wife
cigar taking over control as editor in
1958 Superman began to see massive
expansions to his powers and Superman
volume 1 issue number 146 in 1961
Weisinger consolidated all of the
information regarding Superman's powers
as well as the basis behind them
eliminated what he didn't want
and kept what he considered to be
material that would create for more
compelling stories and serve his
ultimate goal considered by many
comic-book historians to be a soft
reboot of sorts for the Man of Steel's
powers why say you're establish that
Superman had incredible strength a
physical body and clothing that could
not be harmed by any weapon on the face
of the earth including atomic bombs
x-ray vision they could see through
walls and melt steel and that he
operated as a servant of the common man
and protector of the earth furthermore
Superman's flight had always been an
aspect of his powers and that as a baby
his flight would manifest itself but he
had no control of it to achieve control
over this ability to fly during his
teenage years as Superboy Jonathan Ken
had helped him to master his control
over flying in a similar capacity to
learning how to ride a bike with
training wheels and so with these powers
established Weisinger took the next step
of forming their basis by stating that
the extreme gravity on Krypton caused
the muscles of Kryptonians to become
extremely dense and that when Superman
arrived on earth by default the lighter
of gravity of Earth allowed for
SuperSpeed reflexes strength and
invulnerability in addition to this
because Krypton had a red Sun instead of
the Sun suppressing abilities it simply
didn't activate the portion of the brain
that allow
four powers on the other hand the Yellow
Sun of Earth energized this portion of
the brain and awakened Superman's powers
of x-ray vision telescopic vision and
the like and so following this
consolidation between 1960 and 1970
Superman's powers were expanded on
within the context of stories and based
largely on the situation itself rather
than the practicality of the power in
question as a result fans were met with
a series of increasingly ridiculous
displays of powers like 1960 once Action
Comics issue number 273 where Superman
sneezed a galaxy out of existence in
1967 Superboy issue number 120 where he
pulled a chain of planets out of a dying
galaxy while some of these abilities
were only featured once and never seen
again do you see it taken no steps to
retcon these powers meaning that over
the course of his lifetime leading up to
the conclusion of the Silver Age
Superman had amassed the powers of time
travel and vulnerability faster than
light travel
super speed hearing and strength as well
as telepathy telekinesis heat vision
hypnosis among others and so by 1970
with Krypto the dog Supergirl Superboy
and the rest of the super family in
existence all of whom who possessed the
same level of strength and powers of
Superman Weisinger retired from DC
Comics and in this place came Julius
Schwartz as a protagonist and firm
believer in the practical nature of
powers rather than the godlike displays
of Superman's stories under Weisinger
Schwartz believed that Superman's powers
had systematically destroyed the ability
for source and esteem to create
compelling stories and in turn sought to
return the Man of Steel to this golden
age roots by reducing his powers to
one-third of what they had been during
the 1960's with Superman issue number
233 Julie Schwartz initiated a series
commonly referred to as the Sandman saga
and the events of this story a
scientists been attempting to power a
machine using the energy of Kryptonite
but when the experiment went awry all
kept tonight on earth was rendered inert
and had no effect on Superman continuing
the trend of retcon of the Man of Steel
Julius Schwartz introduced the sand
Superman as a byproduct of the
experimental failure and the elimination
of kryptonite a portal was formed
between Earth and the quorum dimension
while only appearing for the sake of
this story a fraction of the corne
dimension psychic energy manifested on
earth where it took on the form of a
sand version of Superman draining power
from the Man of Steel each time Superman
engaged in battle but looking to take on
the role of a superhero at the
conclusion of the Stoll
the two came to the realization that
sans Superman consisted of negatively
charged to energy while Superman
consisted of positively charged energy
and then if the two were to touch it
would start a chain reaction that would
destroy the earth engage it a stalemate
thus an Superman made the decision to
return to his own dimension with
Superman refusing to have his vast
powers returned to him as a result while
he maintained most of his prominent
abilities the powers of hypnosis time
travel on the like were removed leaving
him with powers similar to his Golden
Age form while the intention of Julius
Schwartz was rooted in the desire to
make Superman more relatable for fans
Superman was a larger-than-life hero and
his role in the DC Universe had to
reflect that and so within one issue of
The Sandman sagas completion Julius
Schwartz was removed for the title and
in the publications leading up to crisis
on Infinite Earths Superman's Silver Age
powers were slowly restored